well this past weekend was a big one as
far as local entertainment goes we had
the fight we've got
the garth concert shows and the grand
opening of delilah
las vegas and all weekend long
superstars like justin bieber
vegas resident dj steve aoki andrea day
megan fox and machine gun kelly just to
name a few
stopped by delilah inside the wind to
check out the modern day
supper club oh yeah there was drake the
kardashians too wow
my friend said and i quote it was a
movie
and besides the entertainment and fun
delilah is all about the fine dining
experience as well i got a sneak peek of
their menu
with the executive chef who is also a
las vegas native
take a look just when i thought i
couldn't love the win
any more than i already do they open up
delilah one of my favorite places in los
angeles right here
with a vegas twist now it's time to see
what's cooking
besides all the vibes
[Music]
this executive chef here of delilah josh
smith so tell us
what is on the menu thank you rocky so
we're we're in the bubble bar
upstairs at delilah and we're serving
you our strawberry shortcake baked
alaska made with harry's berries
strawberries
so on the outside you'll see toasted
italian meringue and on the inside it's
like an ice cream cake
there's a layer of pound cake and on top
of that there's
vanilla ice cream strawberry ice cream
strawberry compote
we've got a strawberry coulis and we're
going to flambe with some cognac
of that cognac and we'll get that
lit on fire we will flambe the dessert
table side like this
and this is when you get your phones out
in instagram
and then we're gonna douse out that oh
my gosh
flame with some strawberry coulis oh
wait i didn't get the shortcake so you
have to get every layer in there right
that is perfect obviously this is just
dessert but you have
so we kind of you know the way that we
approach this it's a fancy dessert but
we give it a really comfortable familiar
name like
like strawberry shortcake right so i
thought about that throughout the menu
so we do
dover soul fish and chips we do a surf
and turf that's with scallops and short
rib
you know there's a lot of really
familiar preparations on the menu
kind of the way we thought about it so
it's a supper club you know with uh
you know modern luxury ingredients but
you know really approachable
preparations of the foods our cocktails
are amazing made by marina mercer
who's our property mixologist for the
win you know one that i really love is
the
the stepford wife so it's like a uh a
french 75
it's got a strawberry and this edible
perfume that she spritzes over the glass
now chef what's the difference between
the los angeles menu that everyone knows
and loves and the vegas menu the owners
john and brian did want me to make the
chicken tenders and the burger the same
way they do in la which i was really
proud to do
we also do the carrot souffle that's a
chasing's original that's on the los
angeles menu but those are the only
three savory items that they really
wanted me to stick with from la
okay so the rest of the menu was up to
me to create so we you know we made a
really comfortable menu
with luxury ingredients you know to
match this beautiful room
in true vegas fashion you have a late
night menu too so tell people what they
can expect there that's right so after
about 11 pm we'll switch over to a late
night menu and there's
fried chicken sliders there's a shrimp
cocktail on that menu
my grandmother's gooey cake is on that
menu a nice little sweet surprise on the
menu we're also doing
a late night breakfast sandwich so
there's like a homemade sausage
we make our own english muffin and then
make a fondue of mimolet cheese that
goes over that
breakfast sandwich that's available late
night only that is that sounds
so good right after you're done partying
yeah
i mean where else can you have bottle
service and enjoy you know a dj and a
night out and then order some late night
food so it's
it's very unique it's very special
so fabulous right let's go what are we
doing here
how about try to make your reservation
um and you might get in like after
september
let's make it out so i'm looking forward
to it yeah it's crazy but
let's